In this lesson, we're going to take a look at view modes and visualizers.
So let's get started.
One of them you can look at underneath optimization view modes.
You'll find that underneath our show.
And in there you'll see light complexity.
Light complexity will let us know if our lights are movable, stationary, or static and cover
them associated to their complexity.
Overlapping movable lights are the most expensive to work with.
You can resize the radius will help when it comes to stationary lights and them overlapping
each other because you can only do four overlapping at a time when it comes to baking.
Static lights are basically free.
They're really cheap to work with.
And so you can put as many as necessary.
But also keep in mind your geometry and how long things are going to take to bake.
Let's go and take a look at that up close and unreal.
And I'll bring up a few points that are also known in lumen.
So in our scene here, we can quickly check here what it looks like for a light complexity.
So I'm going to go under lit here.
And we're going to go down, not show.
If I said show, please excuse me.
We want to do lit.
So under lit, we want to go in here and we want to take a look at our optimization view
modes.
And there you'll see light complexity.
This shows us where the complexity of our light is at.
And we see one light here, which is stationary, has quite a few areas here that it's taken
into account that are kind of expensive.
Now some of the geometry is coming in black because it's using a level instance to be
able to build it.
But you can see these lights.
Here's another one here, also stationary, how they affect each other as I move them
around.
These stationaries show me where the overlap is happening with another stationary light,
case in point, this rec light.
So if I have more than four overlapping, and I'll demonstrate over here in this green area.
If I go to say my point light, I'm pulling one and I'll pull in two and I pull in three.
And then if I pull in a fourth one, you'll see that one of them has an X going on.
not really doing and pulling the weight like he's supposed to.
He's not quite working like he should as a stationary light.
He's more moved into movable just for this to be more manageable because these four overlapping
plus we have a directional light in place.
So we've kind of hit our limit.
So these three are being counted plus our directional light.
So what we can do to remedy that is one, if again, this is a baking scenario, I can lower
the the attenuation or I can move it out of an area of influence.
And when you do, you'll actually see the X go away.
This guy's going to stick around for a bit because we have quite a bit of lights in here,
two directional lights, several wrecks, as well as as well as a few others in here.
So that's something to consider.
But this will tell you the complexity of it all.
Another mode we have is called light map density.
Let's take a look at that up close and some things to keep in mind when working with this.
So let me go ahead and remove these lights that we just created.
Don't need them.
And you'll see the colors change as I get rid of them.
Red is very high.
White is really high.
And green, as you can tell, is pretty light on the importance or complexity scale.
So let's go from optimization view modes here.
And we're going to go to our light map density.
Now the light map density shows me how my settings are set for each one of these pieces
of geometry.
So let's pick something that's not merged or in a level instance, something that's a
little more singular.
So I'm going to grab this here and I'm going to scroll to the area where it shows us where
a light map information is at.
Now for some reason you can't find it.
You'll find it right underneath the lighting and you can also do a search for light map
and you'll see the resolution set here.
You can see this is pretty low.
And I'm fortunate enough that I'm not getting any blobby shadows.
But if I was, I might want to increase this to be the same light map resolution as the
ground.
We're fortunate enough because both of these, even though this is a smaller item, have the
same light map resolution.
So we're doing okay.
But if for some reason this is really high resolution.
Let's say the arch is set to like, I don't know, we have like, I shouldn't say really
high, but you know, you don't want to go too high with these.
You want to keep it reasonable.
So say this is like a one, a 512.
It's a real little, little over the top.
It could be one, one, 28.
Okay.
But it's a five, so it's really getting close on click really good.
But then down on the ground, it's only, it's left at 64.
As soon as this object hits this area and they connect with each other, I could get
a blobby shadow just because it, Unreal's trying to bake that light map on there.
And it is trying to evaluate the difference between these two resolutions for that light
map.
So just keep those things in mind if you are baking that those might be an issue.
In this previous scene, let's take a brief look again at some of the visualizers like
we talked about in the first class when it comes to Lumen.
So we have lit here and over here we have Nanite visualization.
So if I do an overview, I've now converted, I right clicked in the content browser and
I converted all of these chairs into a Nanite object.
So you can view that ahead of time if you want to.
So we can say, hey, let's look at our Nanite visualization.
Now you can look at mass, the triangles, how they're clustered together, what's going on
with the primitives, how the calculations working, instances of those objects, the overdraw
that might occur if it's really high detail, material ID that's involved, UV, light map,
UV going on, so if you are using that, and evaluate world position offset.
So all these things can be listed within the overview.
So if I click on overview, you'll see that each one of these are in each different category.
This is the nice thing about overview, you can just pick and look at what you need.
In this case, we'll focus on the triangles.
So if I move around, you'll notice in some instances, and in this case, the chair is
really simple, but if let's go and switch the triangles here, you will see those triangles
flip and recalculate based on distance of the camera from the object.
So I'll go to triangles here for the whole thing.
And in this case, since these chairs are super simple, you're not going to see it as much,
but you would see it on high resolutions, scanned rock objects, you'll see those triangles
shift according to the distance we are to the object.
And you may see a little bit of it.
You see the top of the chairs kind of shift a little bit.
That is unreal trying to give us the best possible geometry based on distance using
Nanite, and Nanite is a lot more efficient because it gives you a higher resolution at
lower cost when it comes to your geometry.
So it's pretty cool to be able to see that ahead of time.
We also talked about in the first class, the lumen overview, which shows our geometry normals,
our reflection view with our hardware ray tracing involved here, lumen pink missing
surface catch coverage.
So it tells you where the errors or situations you might have or issues you may have in your
scene.
So it's actually pretty cool to be able to take a look at that really quick.
We also have our virtual shadow maps.
So in here we can look at the shadow mask.
It shows you how things are being amassed into our scene, almost as if you're seeing
a real time update bake.
But in this case, when it comes to virtual shadow maps, they are updating on the fly
and they're actually not picked at all.
We have a clip map level.
You could see it sorting and popping in as we go through here and you can see that it's
working and doing and digesting things based on location.
Next we have virtual page.
Again, this works kind of like we saw with the Nanite.
So you can see it bring in what we need based on our positioning and it's trying to sort
through the data and the objects in the scene and where our light is positioned.
We also have the catch page, which simply is showing us how things are being catched
and called upon.
Going back to the topic of light mass and volumetric light maps.
Light maps, light mass in this case, creates a volumetric area in which objects can be
calculated.
Again, this is a baking scenario.
These volumetric light maps allow objects to be calculated in the shadows to update
for stationary lights.
You can actually see this ahead of time in a baking scenario.
Let me show you what I mean.
So in Unreal, I can go in here and I can show, take a look at these components here.
Now at any time you can choose, I'll just briefly talk about this.
You can see Lumen and Nanite have some extra areas to be able to visualize things.
You'll see an overall visualizer.
We can add some more advanced stuff.
So don't get confused.
It's easy to get lost with this, but we're going to focus mainly on showing where that
light mass mapping is happening.
So let's go back over there.
We're going to visualize.
I'm going to go to that light map area.
Volumetric light map right there.
And it shows you the calculations.
It shows you all of this.
These spheres are points of calculation in here in our world so that our shadows can
correctly update and work according to our geometry and our objects in our scene.
Pretty cool.
Now you can increase that resolution if you want to.
I like to use it.
I think at default it works pretty darn well, but you'll see down here, there's a detailed
cell size.
As you increase that, you can increase some of the quality.
But it also is going to require a bit more brick memory.
You can also increase that if needed.
You can smooth things out if you need to.
Again, this is the volumetric light map.
This again helps with our characters and how they're working in our world and how those
shadows are being established.
Let's look at some tips and tricks real quick here for light mass.
So indirect quality lighting doesn't work on preview quality presets.
You want to make sure that if you want to get exactly what you planned and you want
to get the highest resolution for your bake, and you want to make sure you have a good
representation of what you've chosen, you really do want to make sure you have it on
production.
But you can start off low and do preview and medium and high, but eventually find yourself
at production if you're noticing you're missing some of the details that you know you put
in there, such as increasing your indirect lighting quality and so forth.
So ways to improve and optimize light baking, better UVs for light maps, override light
map resolution per object.
So your hero objects will have a higher resolution.
Optimization view modes, check things with that, show light components, and compressed
light maps are set to off.
Now briefly, I want to go back to view modes for a second because I want to point out one
more thing.
So in Unreal, underneath our optimization view modes, you'll notice there's also the
overlap which we talked about, but there's also shader complexity, as well as shader
complexity, quads and quad overdraw.
Quad overdraw will show us exactly where our density is at in our scene and where things
might be getting pulled a bit stronger with our memory.
In this case, this isn't too bad because we still have our spheres, which are a little
bit dense. And back here, we could definitely merge these.
We go over that in our optimization course.
But you'll notice we're doing pretty well.
As soon as we introduce trees or other items, we definitely want to look at maybe
switching to lumen and then also switching those larger, higher poly objects to nanite.
Here I have a screen showing some ways in which you can better get better results using
light baking, such as number of indirect lighting bounces.
You'll see there's five here and we'll also see the indirect lighting quality set to 20
and indirect lighting. So this is point zero point five.
And you get some really nice stuff going on here.
Now, the more you increase your bounces, keep in mind, you may not see a difference if
you go past like 10 because the eye is not going to pick up those bounce upon another
bounce upon another bounce.
So it'll be very minute changes.
You can also make a static object glow.
So if you have like some simple lights in a city scene, you can actually bake that in
there. If you wanted to, you could even do that for on the real cheap, bake it ahead
of time and still use lumen if you are afraid of noise and the objects, you know, are
static, such as maybe a car and a neon light that would actually work pretty well.
But just keep in mind, if your characters walk in front of that bake, they're not going
to get that light. So just be aware of it.
Here's a link here diving deeper into those topics that we talked about in the next
lesson. We're going to take a look at screen space GI.
Thanks again.